hey everyone how's it going today I am
joining to my good friend Charlie hi
would you like to talk a little bit
about what you do and who you are sure
so like my ocher I work in tech but I'm
a designer rather than an engineer but
for a small tech company and I also make
youtube videos about design yeah so
today I wanted to ask Charlie about all
things design I know a lot of y'all are
really interested in what the other
roles are in tech and so I thought I
would do a little bit of an interview
and ask about what it's like to be a
designer so the first question I want to
ask you Charlie is what types of
designer roles are there in the tech
industry in general so in the tech
industry in particular they usually
split into kind of two different
categories there's the marketing design
and the product design so the marketing
design is basically everything about
building the tech product itself
so yeah product design can have UX
designers which is user experience
there's UI designers which focus more on
like the visuals that you end up seeing
them yet user researchers as well all of
those roles are about designing the
product and then the marketing design
rules are about design marketing the
clues in the name
but yeah they tend to be split into
those different categories and depending
on how big the company is generally
affects how granular the roles get
within each of those yeah yeah and like
when we talk about product I think we're
talking about things like the actual app
yes I swear yeah yeah yeah so marketing
tends to be things like what's on the
website talking about the product after
emails or stuff like that
yeah brand collateral this conferences
or the signage for that that sort of
thing yeah cool so I'm curious what is a
typical day for you as a designer right
so I should say that I'm a marketing
designer so I fall into that category in
the design so I mostly am designing
websites and also building them for my
company I work for convertkit which is
an email marketing software company in a
typical day I would have a typical week
rather I'd have a couple of big projects
on so like the main ones and then is
little things to fit in through that and
my team has quite a flexible like work
schedule we're all quite autonomous so I
kind of get to decide some priorities
and things like that so I'll generally
set my own schedule for the day just
always making sure I'm working on the
most important thing to get that done
involves a lot of talking with
stakeholders in the team so normally if
you're a designer you might have a
client right you're doing the design for
and when you work on a team at a tech
company your client is usually one of
your teammates like the person who's
requested that this job be completed so
I'll talk with them get what they need
from the project and then go ahead and
design it and be in charge of producing
it essentially cool yeah I want to click
on clicking on that a little bit what
types of problems are you solving from a
day-to-day basis yeah what are the
things that you you think through when
you're designing things throughout the
week so usually on the marketing side in
particular it's about conversion a lot
of the time converting people who visit
the website into paying customers or
like signing up for a trial whatever it
is that your product does so that's
something that I'm always thinking about
and working with data and unless we have
on our team for doing testing to see
what little design tweaks we can make to
improve that interesting note there that
can give us an example is that recently
we ran a test changing the colors of the
buttons on our website oh just to see
like if this color made people click
more than this other color
yeah and they did yeah so that's really
cool so let get to be very granular and
do a little test to improve conversion
rates this I'd say the main problem
other problems are generally like
awareness and communicating a certain
message so for example our sales team
would go into a conference and they need
like a one-page sheet to really explain
to people what our product does and who
uses it so it's up to me to design that
information in a way that's I catching
some people on a cat like take the
pamphlet mm-hmm and also so that it's
easy to read and understand as well yeah
that's the thing that I was surprised
about when I started working in tech
that designers are intentional about
everything yes like if you look at a
website or an app or anything and you
look at every single little thing like
why is the button round
yeah or like why is the or where the
words arranged in this order are also so
intentional and there's kind of like I
think that's kind of beautiful like yeah
that's really awesome it's like I like
to think of design it's the in-between
of art and science
so like yes you're making things look
good but it's with a certain purpose and
to achieve a certain goal yeah so it's
like if something looks great but it
doesn't achieve the goal of increasing
conversions then it's not a successful
design and if it increases conversions
but it doesn't look great and people
lose respect for our brand because of it
and it doesn't like seem as high-quality
in the brand perception then that's not
a good solution either so you're gonna
meet in the middle yeah in a way means
you have to know like people really well
yeah for sure
yeah you have to know your audience who
you're designing for and really
understand the problem so I spend a lot
of time at the start of a project
understanding the problem before I dive
in and start designing yeah yeah like I
guess one clarification there is like
people like designers are also people so
it's not like you'll all have this
insight into Hugh the human condition
yeah more so than everybody else yeah
but that's part of the job of like
getting to know who you're building and
doing a lot of tests like user
researchers yes that's their whole job
right yeah and it's also about realizing
that your personal preference and your
personal opinion isn't what matters here
it's what the audience is gonna be
attracted to yeah yeah totally okay so
there's this one myth that I feel like
I've heard a lot that actually I thought
about when I was in college but do you
have to be good at art to be a designer
nope you don't I am terrible at drawing
and I always thought this would hold me
back as a designer mm-hmm I always
thought that I couldn't do it because I
can't draw a perfect circle or anything
like that
you don't at all have to be good at art
to be a designer you have to have a good
taste which is something that can be
learned by like consuming a lot of good
content but you'll figure out the skills
that you need to like achieve that level
of taste as US you learn it you don't
have to be good at art before you become
a designer is what I'm saying yeah that
is really interesting I was really
surprised to learn that I was like
really
I can't draw a circle like ya either so
there's actually these into my next
question of like how does one become a
designer do you go to school is there a
major that people choose or are there
programs or is it something that is
learned more through a different job
maybe so there's a couple of different
ways to become a designer you can go to
school or you could be self-taught if
you wanted to the main misconception I
see people have is that it's all about
learning the software so they think oh
I'm gonna learn Photoshop and that's
gonna make me a good designer that's not
really what design is about that is like
a means to an end what's more important
for you to learn is design principles
Design Thinking so those are like some
terms you can search for if you're
wanting to teach yourself that's why I
personally went to design school because
there was a program that led me through
everything I needed to know
to become a designer and that just
seemed easier you know when I was 18 you
know what I was doing right yeah I found
design school really useful if you are
going to choose a design program I would
suggest choosing a school that
specializes in design or like it's known
for its design program in particular
you're gonna get the best results that
way I think if you're spending money on
school it might as well be a good one
yeah yeah is there a specific like name
of a design program because I can
imagine there's things like material
design right or like graphic designs
yeah that all kind of fit into this
world of design there one specific one
or several specific ones that are good
for becoming a designer in the tech
industry I would say focus in terms of
look for as visual communication design
that's what my major was in my Bachelor
of design that I did and also looking at
Web Design I suppose then user
experience it's a good thing to focus on
but just make sure whatever program
you're choosing focuses more on the like
I said design thinking skills and like
layout and typography and that sort of
thing more so than teaching how to code
teaching how to use Photoshop I think
those are things you can very easily
learn yourself like and you know
supplement your skills so your school
might touch on those but you can improve
on them in your own time and those other
things soft skills I guess they call
them I don't know are harder to learn so
yeah but similar to engineering I think
yeah I was like learning the concepts
about computer science and also learning
like this
skills of like how to empathize with
people yes how to write good code what
looks like good code is a thing that's
harder to learn than like how to use an
IDE how to run your program like those
tools and stuff are means to get to the
ultimate goal but the things that like
help you make those decisions while
using those tools are the things that
are really valuable to learn so it
sounds like it's pretty simple yeah it
does yeah and I think that's the
difference often between a good designer
and a great designer is the one who
focuses more on their you know design
thinking in principle side of things and
it sounds like it'll be the same for
engineering yeah
can I throw in like a kind of wild card
question yeah is there like an app or
website or something that you really
really just love the design of ooh I
mean lots I feel like it's a designer I
like collect beautiful things and I'm
always looking at examples mm-hmm I'm
Squarespace has a beautiful marketing
site they're one of my favorites they're
always doing a lot of a bee testing as
well on their homepage if you visit
their site often which I do and you'll
often notice it changing as they're
trying new things out and I think that's
really cool yeah they do a lot of custom
photography and things as well yeah so
in addition to the stuff that you just
talked about about learning things like
design principles and design patterns
what are other useful skills that people
should learn if they want to become a
designer I think that you need to have
like this innate sense of curiosity and
problem-solving is something really
important when the skill to have so
being able to think critically about
things is a great skill to have us a
designer not just in terms of critiquing
work and being able to look at that and
say all that font size is wrong with
things like that but more so thinking
outside the box when it comes to problem
solving not just going with the most
obvious solution that's something again
that can be learned with practice and
the more you do things and the more you
surround yourself with other designers
that will come to you yeah again that
feels so similar just offer engineering
because I would say that's also true
like software engineers or innate
problem solvers mm-hm and so I it almost
makes me wonder like what's even the
difference sort of but it is like what
you're actually producing at the end and
how you're doing it is do yes and so
maybe it has to do with like how you
think about problems and how you go
about solving them and what tools do you
enjoy using
might be like the small difference that
it takes between you becoming in a
designer and a software engineer yeah
for sure yeah
cool okay so we're on in a last question
okay and I wanted to ask how did you get
into design like Wright made you want to
become a designer so it was actually
album at like hubs of CDs Wow I'm a big
music fan and I just like loved the idea
that there was this picture essentially
on the cover that represented the music
inside I just thought that was so cool
yeah and like that could make me want to
buy a CD as if it had really cool cover
art you know so that's what got me
interested in design and yeah I had
studied graphics for a while and then
switched over to web and I still love
album covers have you ever had a chance
to design an album cover for someone no
not yet that is on like the design
bucket list Oh gotcha well you did you
design the book recently right yes I did
design a book recently so that was like
definitely another chick yeah closer to
the album yeah that'll be like the peak
of my career go see it awesome so I
think that's it um Charlie to actually
talks a lot about design on her channel
so definitely go check it out we
actually filmed another video on her
channel about working in tech and
emotions and stuff um it's really
similar to the video that I put out a
little bit ago about emotions and so
we're talking about how it feels to be
kind of an emotional person in tech yeah
work so yeah I'll go check it out on her
channel but yeah thank you all so much
for watching hope you liked it if you
did give it a thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe and thanks for being on my
channel you added me alright see you
next time